[Music]  when you made the first movie it wasn't  possible but now 20 years later they're  talking about private citizens traveling  in spaces that's something you might  want to do no no no you have no interest  in traveling in space no okay no for  heaven's sakes I'm oh you seem angry  about the question yeah you seem in a  rage rage don't weave this but with your  exaggerated with your your with your  talent for exaggeration something like  that  no you wouldn't want to do that I  wouldn't want to either Annie you don't  want to go to space do you think so no  screw it not until we're you know we can  go just to go out and be in space yeah  it's like just sitting in an RV even  worse even worse the motor home has  comforts that that thing that I'm sure  yeah okay and I'm a people person I like  to be around you guys three of us up in  space well if you were there it's really  not not joke so thank you we could kill  I thought you could kill a lot of times  this one man did  you